tension and Chaos outside Argentina's
Congress as a debate rages inside on
whether to pass Argentina's president
jaier M so-called Omnibus Bill aimed at
modernizing the country's economy not
everyone is happy with the change the
president wants for
Argentina the only way jav can impose
his Ultra liberal model is with
repression he wants to delete workers
rights in Argentina with the bill and we
won't allow it we'll be on the streets
fighting back
this has been the situation outside
Congress as the law is being debated
with hundreds of protesters trying to
make it to the building and the police
using pepper spray water cannons in
order to prevent it kavan mle came to
power with a promise to transform
Argentina to modernize the economy to
attract foreign investments but he will
be confronting with Argentina's powerful
labor unions and with thousands of
people on the streets willing to
challenge him M responded to the
violence outside congress with this
controversial tweet a lioning congress
opening a cage or a prison for the
thousands of protesters on the
streets the bill initially contained
over 600 law but has now been reduced to
over 200 as the president was forced to
give in to the demands of other
political parties the new package gives
the president emergency powers for a
year allows for the privatization of 37
State companies and modernize the
exploitation of fossil
fuels Argentina is an intensive care and
it's seriously addicted to a drug the
drug is the deficit and the symptom is
inflation peronism is the drug dealer
Argentina needs to get rid of this
addiction because we wouldn't have a
future
otherwise the Omnibus Bill is the new
President's first big political test
that mle had a decision to make he could
say I'm going to go for as much as I can
go right at the beginning to have a
strong impact to make use of my
political Capital because I've just been
elected and so on and then we can see
how this battle goes or you can say I'm
going to take these things on one by one
I don't want to have too too many
enemies at the same time he's chosen the
first M promises his austerity measures
and reforms will bring down soaring
inflation in Argentina and jumpstart the
economy
but these images of repression on the
streets show how difficult the months
ahead will be and how the president is
willing to confront those who dare
oppose him there is alj
Buenos make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer